foreign
[Music]
I've watched a lot of people talk about
this game but there was something about
it that didn't really pique my interest
so I'd been brushing it aside but for
some reason one night when my wife was
out and my kids were all in bed I
thought screw it let's see what this is
all about I didn't even know if the open
Beta was still going
given the choice of three characters
I've picked one purely on looks alone
Ajax it looked like a beast
the initial missions were pretty stale
to be honest but there were obviously
more around teaching the player the
mechanics so I pushed on and the next
thing I remember I've been playing for
six hours straight
after that night I continued to play
through the beta until it was eventually
closed down a day or so later
there is more to this game that can
initially be seen from the outside and
it definitely surprised me in a number
of ways
in this video I'd like to discuss
various aspects of this game and why I
think I'll actually be putting a bit of
time into it when it's finally released
a century ago the world was thrusted to
turmoil The vulgus Intruders From
Another Dimension descended Upon Our
realm leaving a trail of shattered
castles and using Humanity as both
sacrifices and experimental fodder
then came the Colossus Titanic beings
that lived nothing unscathed in their
wake
survivors of this Relentless Onslaught
banded together finding refuge in the
stronghold of Albion as they readied
themselves for an inevitable Reckoning
yet hope emerged from an unexpected
Source the magisters a unique faction
among the vulgars known for their
unparalleled technical prowess and they
chose to stand beside Humanity in this
dire hour
and the majesters brought with them an
enigmatic power hidden within the human
genome known as RK
recognizing this gift is a genuine
Legacy with boundless potential they
joined forces with the humans leading to
unprecedented advancements
the Clashing of swords and shields was
replaced with a thunderous Roar of guns
and the fiery Embrace of gunpowder
a select few Among The Chosen awakened
The RK transforming into the beings
known as descendants
descendants possess both superhuman
strength and Arcane abilities akin to
the mythical ancestors mentioned only in
ancient records
each descendant wields the power to
confront the vulgars alone and when
United their standards a formidable
Force Hitler vanquishing even a Colossus
empowered by The magister's Cutting Edge
technology descendants have rekindled
the Flames of Hope across the continent
but Peril still lose
the fate of Ingress now rests in the
hands of these extraordinary beings as
they March towards Ingress a dire threat
emerges in the form of Corel a newly
ascended leader of the volgus wielding
more power than ever before determined
to sow destruction
in this perilous era the Peace of
Ingress lies within the grasp of The
Descendants and Heritage of their power
from the ancestors they rise to meet the
challenges that threatened to plunge
their world into Eternal Darkness
after running through the initial
mission where you're given a basic
overview of the controls you end up in
Albion this is your main Hub think of it
as like the tower in Destiny it's the
area where you'll see other players
running around visit shops and upgrade
stations and intermission areas to
upgrade your tasks it will also continue
the story through interactions with NPCs
with cutscenes Etc
fortunately most missionaries can easily
be fast traveled to or nearby I never
felt like I had to be running for a
ridiculous amount of time
the World areas that I experienced were
nice looking and well put together and
had a good amount of verticality which
is great given that you have a grappling
hook so you can fling yourself around
the map with ease however I did notice
there were a large amount of invisible
walls if you end up going too crazy
sadly the look and feel doesn't feel as
crisp as other open world losers that
have been around for many years and the
areas generally felt quite small
repetitive and lifeless Encounters in
the open world don't just happen and
there isn't enemies just plodding around
they need to be activated via the
mission beacons something I quite liked
is how open world felt it was quite
often I would end up running into other
players running smaller missions and it
felt quite smooth jumping in and giving
them a hand or perhaps avoiding them and
going and doing my own thing this sort
of interaction helped keep the world
feel a Little More Alive yet didn't make
me feel forced to play with others if I
didn't want to
every descendant has their own skill set
and play style I only had the chance to
play with one but it was pretty fun even
if he was supposed to be used as a more
defensive playstyle which usually
wouldn't be what I'd go for I still
found some really good use out of her
skills and they were just flashy enough
to be super fun to use
games like this often struggle to find a
balance between Gunplay and skills I
think outriders is a good example of
this but the first ascendant seemed to
keep this really balanced proper use of
skills at the appropriate time didn't
render guns useless and vice versa
speaking of which there is a decent
selection of weapon types and ammunition
that you need to keep track of but as
you progress through the game you'll be
upgrading and junking a lot of weapons
based on their DPS and viability however
I did notice this weird sort of aim
compensation thing where I knew I missed
the headshot but I ended up being given
it anywhere it felt like controller
assist but way more obvious
the missions themselves are fairly
straightforward you either Defender
Point Raiden area or fend-off waves and
deliver payloads to a select point there
are also raid bosses you can join as
well where you can take on huge dudes
with other players the one I took on was
called a grave Walker it's a pretty cool
fight where you're thrown into an arena
with other players to take it down
the group I was worth obviously didn't
pay attention to the first tutorial
mission where it told you how to fight
these guys but we still managed to take
it down albeit with zero lives left and
4 seconds to spear as you'd expect the
loot from completing this was totally
worth my while
the rest of the enemies in the game seem
to be a fairly typical archetype like
your grunts your slightly bigger grunts
dudes with big ass Shields dudes that
shoot stuff at you and of course those
types that bum rush you down
there are some other special enemies
like snipers or explodey guys but
nothing too different from what you'll
see in other games
something I did accidentally stumble
across was this crazy horde mode that
initially threw me in on my own but
would eventually have other players join
too that got intense it was probably the
best way to show me that my character
really wasn't as strong as I thought it
was and could use a lot more upgrades
The Descendants are gender and class
locked but they can be dressed up in a
hell of a lot of cool skins and colors
and the beta we were given a ton of
credits and currency to unlock several
kits to ever play around with this but
it's easy to see that this is where the
free-to-play aspect comes in although it
would appear that you can gain these
credits through playing normally this is
where it looks like they're trying to
gain revenue
I'm not against this I think cosmetics
and vanity gear is the way to do it it
doesn't look like they're taking the Pay
to Win model that a lot of games in the
past have failed the user base with I'm
happy to put money into a game that I
really enjoy if anything to help me see
more content be released in the future
but if there is a clear Advantage given
to those who have the money to spend I
very quickly lose interest
look I could talk about this for a while
but I think a king's creation broke it
down the best in this video there should
be a link to this video in the top right
hand corner say hi from Indian if you
check it out
but the build customization seems to
come from the game's loot more
specifically weapons and modules
weapons are obtained in a typical way of
looting or buying and come in a variety
of archetypes SMGs assault rifles
snipers shotguns handguns energy weapons
and more they all use a different ammo
type with some obviously being more rare
than others this pushes players to think
about what weapon they're using or have
equipped depending on the situation
crowd control damage Range close combat
these are all the things that need to be
taken into consideration depending on
the activity however it's the modules
that can really customize the way these
things work like I said earlier I came
in a little late to test this part of
the game properly but it's clearly this
aspect that will give the greatest
customization to the way your descended
plays modules are dropped as Loot and
can be outfitted not just to your
weapons but to your suit as well and
over time these modules will become more
meaningful to your build as loot drops
become better as well as the upgrades
you can perform as your Mastery level
increases
much like weapons you'll end up looting
a lot of these and will have to start
checking on your inner hoarder in order
to not fill your inventory space with
things that could simply be scrapped
the first ascendant is a free-to-play
third-person cross-platform looter
shooter where players take on the role
of a descendant and fight against
invaders for the survival of humanity
I wasn't expecting much but after a
dozen or so hours I was kicking myself
for not having tried it out earlier but
I struggled to explain why
there are so many games that do what the
first decenter does but better the
division's gameplay is better Destiny's
World building is better Warframe has a
deep customization progression and even
anthem had more powerful graphics with
skills and vertical gameplay
but the first ascendant is just fun
it's also quite unique in a way that
someone who is familiar with this genre
can just pick it up and start playing at
a reasonable level without having to
place hundreds of hours into it yet
there is more than enough for someone
who likes to grind and spend
considerable time and obsessing of the
detail around builds Etc
I really hate when people say well it's
fun to play with friends is a reason why
a game is good because with the right
friends you can make a game out of
kicking around a bag of and be
entertained
however this is probably the best way
that I think I can explain this
it doesn't do anything new but the first
descendant is just super easy to pick up
and jump into and like I keep saying
it's it's just fun
plus being free to play only helps make
it easier to convince others to give it
a try
I'm not super confident on what the
in-game has for us at this stage but
I'll sure as hell be putting in the
hours to see what it has to offer
when it comes out I can see my wife
jumping in on the Xbox and teaming up
with me on the PC with her spending
several hours at a time screaming
obsidian tease at the TV
which is a very vocal gamer so I'm sorry
in advance if you happen to stumble
across us out in the open world if her
mic is hot you'll um likely learn some
things
anyway thank you very much for watching
and I'll catch you in the next one
cheers
[Music]